ciao a tutti allora io questo video volo
postarlo tipo un mese fa per lo riesce a
trovare un modo carino per farlo mi
spiego allora è mai capitato di avere
mal di testa
ecco solitamente i rimedi più gettonati
sono veri caffè prendere una medicina
mettere gli occhiali dormire
il che è molto utile per la
considerazione che facevo è che
dall'avvento di internet tutti quanti
fanno affidamento del web su tutto ecco
cosa accadrebbe se dovessimo tipo
credere tutto quello che leggiamo la
vedono un botto di tempo mi sono
riuscito a dare una risposta ma non so
se vi piacerà
giaretta
sapevo che saresti venuto
[Musica]
credo
tutto a posto scusate ma che un ottimo a
stendermi a letto
ho un po di mal di testa
speriamo stia bene
[Musica]
sai se fosse rimasta al 32 secondi
l'inizio del vero schizzate le ovaie
dalla gola
come dire che c'è pronto gesto o ma che
fai è su apri la bocca famiglie le
tonsille e mi fa male la testa
non so trash di là rotola melo al rotolo
mele 33 trentini entrano 31 pt 33
trotterellando non ce la faccio mai e
vuoi fare l'amore no ho mal di testa
chiamiamo medico
no un esorcista no un becchino no ho
solo un po di mal di testa
lei capisco
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non ci stanno sentiva le consistenze le
fonti
nausea
[Musica]
mi racconti janet cosa è successo
io sto per sposarmi ma credo che la
ragazza non è un problema di salute
coperto a dirlo è che ho visitato
vogliamo potrebbe morire da un momento
all'altro e lo capisse il suo cranio per
gonfiarsi come uno scroto enormi
consegnarsi fino a farlo sembrare un
enorme scroto cacchio
e come se non bastasse potrebbe poi
essere che sei stato fecondato da
un'area la situazione sembra essere
delle più da me ne guardi non credo alla
mail non c'era più da un bel po di tempo
capisco che adesso lei mi aspetti qui io
vado di là un attimo a fare una cosa poi
torno subito tocca subito
perché era prete sono stessa dice cose
senza senso
lei prenda questa una mela al giorno
toglie il medico di torno
janet ho portato anche per lei una testa
[Musica]
sorella
[Applauso]
figliolo
sto guardando quei giovani peccaminosi
che c'è quando al calcio
si senta sorella io non voglio dì
qualcosa però sono più qui per chiedere
un consiglio un super meat egitto e
trova il mio ragazzo ha un problema
secondo me sta per morire cosa fa eco
del tuo ragazzo falso beh io non lo so
vorrei scusarmi tanto col mio ragazzo e
vorrei fare tanti bambini e ti piace
fare i bambini contenuti si giochiamo
spesso io e lui stesso ammise che satana
satana satana e regione forse è stato
indemoniato da qualcuna e quindi erano
che spettano con la mente savona so cosa
posso fare
[Musica]
janet
sapevo che saresti venuto che stai
facendo qua sopra
mio padre mi ha detto che mi ha cosparso
d'ortaggi ma perché mi hai preso per un
minestrone è troppo tardi
stai cercando di prendermi con te ma che
cosa dice hai urlato sei scappata come
fatto trovarmi non lo so forse forse
sono nato qui perché ho seguito che sei
sposarmi torniamo a casa
no non ha più senso non è più mal di
testa sei stato mutato ormai ma chi ti
ha detto tutto questo google o ancora
una scelta e io sento la libertà
ed è per questo io dal mio piccolo
consiglio di non credere a tutte le
fregnacce che vengono scritte sul web o
che ci vengono dette in generale nella
vita
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]